kayla is starting off this hour in
Columbus Ohio I tell you how are you hi
Dave my husband and I really appreciate
your ministry thank you for taking my
call
thank you how can I help today we have a
problem where last week we just found
out that my husband has 31 thousand
dollars in student loan debt he didn't
know no and the reason why is when he
started college his parents said that
they would take out loans and pay for
his college and then if he would ever
move out get married he would then be
responsible for the college that he
would you know do after that time which
he has after he moved out he started
paying for all of his college out of
pocket so how did these loans end up in
his name
um his parents took them out in his name
I guess that that was a process that
they chose to do you can get his you
can't do that okay he wanted he would
have had to have sign his name well and
and he may have he may have signed his
name but I think he was under the
impression that even though he was
taking out the loans in his name his
parents were going to pay for them oh so
he was at home and wanted the chair why
did they choose not to do that I I do
not know and we've talked to his mother
about his father just passed away a year
and a half ago and kind of all the
financial knowledge went with him his
father did leave his mom a very good sum
of money to pay for all of their debt so
that they could become debt-free and it
was kind of our impression that these
loans would be taken care of with that
when we found about out about the loans
we asked his mom about that she said
that these loans were not his
responsibility so um how much money did
was she left I couldn't say for sure I
know that she's very well taken care of
now I mean millions are five hundred
thousand or five million or and could
close to the millions like over a
million dollars yes yes sir okay and so
why is she not willing to follow through
because that was her deal um she said
that it was a good life lesson for us I
told her that your mother the fact that
your mother's a liar
the mother your mother and father
promised to take care of something and
they didn't and that's a good life
lesson well she said that it was
unrealistic for us live debt-free which
we have so far and and she said that you
know these things just happen and that
that it was our responsibility right now
I've never taken out a loan I've never
borrowed any money and so I'm very
worried about how what would I shall
realize I'm around 30,000 I just
graduated with my master's I was paying
that out of pocket so that will increase
in the near future I'll start water
household income is thirty thousand and
you both have master's degrees though I
have a master's degree he is still
working on his bachelor's degree and
paying out of pocket for school right
now I just graduated with my master's
last month paid out of pocket for that
and your master Allen one science
education or a nursing of science
education so what are you going to do
I'm going to keep at the hospital okay
and you'll be making how much um my my
personal income will probably come up to
about fifty to seventy-five thousand
actually your household in your
household income now is going to be over
a hundred thousand dollars a year so
there's nothing to wring your hands
about you don't have any debt you can
pay off thirty one thousand the the
biggest problem in this conversation is
is that his mother's a liar yeah I agree
that's the biggest problem in the
conversation and I think your husband
needs to sit down with his mom and go
hey mom you and dad said you were going
to take care of this this is not a life
lesson this is you being a bomb mom you
need to freaking follow through the life
lesson is is you're a twerp that's my
life lesson I mean he can be nicer than
that but that's where this conversation
is going to end thirty thousand dollars
worth
quick I mean it's not a life lesson
that's BS now if there's some other
bargain that hit the was struck that I'm
not getting this conversation then I
guess we can talk about it that you have
no legal stand the legal stand is your
husband's $31,000 in debt and so the two
of you are going to take your hundred
thousand our income and pay it off but I
got to tell you me and mom are going to
have a discussion if I'm if I'm your
husband
yeah you're not the position
relationally to have that discussion but
he needs to have his backbone intact and
go over there and bust his mom's chops
because she's acting like a test pilot
for a broom Factory I mean she's out of
control
III agree and that was I guess that's
kind of more of a shock than the amount
of the money is just I mean this just
came out of absolutely nowhere
well it really didn't I mean you guys he
knew the money was there but what came
out of nowhere was of them were digging
on their promise to pay it well and he
had been under the impression that the
loans had been paid he did not know that
the loans were out standards not
outstanding but that they were still
there and I know and if mom had a
hundred thousand dollars to her name and
she was a widow I might change my tone a
little bit but this chicks around a
million bucks well and that's not that
you know where we're starting out where
he was and you know I just graduated
he's getting ready to graduate yeah none
of that matters if she hadn't made the
promise to pay the bill and then as
we're making on the promise or her
husband hadn't daddy
but yeah you guys signed up for the
student let's tie me up for the student
loan debt mom and dad promising you were
going to pay it and now you need to
follow through and pay it and if not you
got to understand I'm going to be
$31,000 for the pissed at you that's my
life lesson yeah and so I'm thinking
your husband's soft-pedal this he's a
little scared of his mom but they don't
do conflict resolution yeah that's what
that's the same thing if he's a little
scared of his mom she does conflict real
well she shoveled $31,000 onto your
kitchen table she's good at it but this
is your husband I'm talking about time
for him to man up that's that's the
story of this right you can't do it he's
got to do it but she's out of line
and you can tell her I said so if she
us - call me I'll talk to her I'd love
to talk to her that'd be a fun call hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind